for
[Music]
Christian
for
[Music]
Christian
hello good evening my name is James
pronounce he and him and whether you're
here in person tonight or online want to
extend a very warm welcome and a thank
you uh we going to get started this
evening with a couple of
announcements first a week from today on
Father's Day Sunday June 16th we will
have a child dedication ceremony during
our
service this is a ceremony that allows
parents to commit to raising their
children in the way of Jesus and us as a
church Community to commit to love and
support these families as they undertake
this sacred role to sign up for that go
ahead and scan the QR
code June 21st and 22nd our table kids
team will be hosting a funay camp for
kids going into kindergarten through
those graduating sixth grade to get get
more details or sign up scan the QR
code now we exit the kingdom of
noise hurry and
productivity now we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and
simplicity Sacred
Space a space for prayer worship and
adoration a space to behold Christ
revelation of God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your
heart may we all come
home thank you would you guys go ahead
and stand with us we're going to get
started Noel is going to start us off
this week and I just want to say we're
so grateful to have her back for the
summer you'll see her up here with
worship she's been at college for her
first year and it's just been a treat to
have her back on the stage with us so
yay thank you Noel and she's going to
get it started on good God so you guys
sing out all right
[Music]
Be Still My
Soul Be Still My
Soul be still and know my God is
here be still my
soul Be Still My
Soul be still and know my God is here
all that I need to know is this you are
a good God maker of heaven calls me his
you are a good God and your heart beats
in my chest you are a good God all that
I have to do is rest you are a good God
[Music]
I won't be
afraid I won't be
afraid I won't be afraid my God is
here and he will make
way he will make
way he will my God is here all that I
need to know is this you are a good gu
the maker of heaven calls me you are a
good God and your heart beats in my
chest you are a good gu all that I have
to do is rest you are the good gu
[Music]
you gave me your eyes you gave me your
heart your spirit flows through my veins
heart you had a plan right from the
start I know who I am cuz I know who you
are you are a good
God you guys you gave me your heart you
had a plan right from the start I know
who I am cuz I know who you are you are
a good God all that I need to know is
this the maker of heaven calls me his
and your heart beats in my chest you are
a
good all that I have to do is RA you
are all that I need to know is this you
are the good God the maker of heaven
calls me you are a good gu and your
heart is in my ch you are the
good all that I have to do is you are
the good God you are a good God you are
a good God you are a good God you are a
good
God all right you kids are dismissed to
go to your classes you can meet them
over there by the doors and they will
lead you
out thank you again kids ministry team
for loving on them week after week so
grateful for
[Music]
youall
SweeTarts and we are going to transition
into the prayers of the people and um
you guys can follow along with me in red
and uh then whenever we get to the point
where there's space feel free to speak
out the requests that you may be
carrying on your heart tonight and then
uh we will end the prayer
together Jesus for this city of saxi
Texas and for every city and community
and all who live in them we pray to you
for the Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the Widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you for the poor and the impressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and
light healing and hope peace and a deep
sense of your
presence amen
[Music]
you are
here moving in our
MST and worship
you and worship
you you are
here working in this
place I worship
you I worship
you you are
here moving in our
midst I worship
you I worship
you you are
here working in this place
I worship
you I worship
you you are way maker Mir worker promise
Keeper in the darkness my God that is
who you
[Music]
are you are way maker Miracle Worker
promise keeper light in the Darkness my
God that is who you
are you are
here touching every
heart I worship
you I worship
you you are
healed healing
every I worship you
worship
you you are
here turn your Li
around I worship
you I worship
you you are
here men in every
heart I worship
you I worship you
you are way maker Miracle Worker promise
keeper light in the darkness my God that
is who you
are you are way maker mirac worker
promise keeper light in the darkness my
God that is who you are
we make Miracle Worker promise keeper
light in the darkness my God that is who
you
are you are way maker heing worker the
promiser light in the darkness my God
that is who you
are that is who you are
are that is who you
[Music]
even when I don't see it you're working
even when I don't feel it you're working
never stop you never stop working never
stop you never stop working even when I
don't see it you're working even when I
don't feel it you're working never stop
you never stop working you never stop
you never
stoping even when I don't feel it you're
working even when I don't feel it you're
working you never stop you never stop
working even when I don't see it you're
working even when I don't feel it you're
working you never stop you never stop
working you never stop you never
stop way maker Miracle Worker promise
keeper light in the darkness my God that
is who you
are you are way maker Miracle Worker
promise keeper light in the darkness my
God that is who you
are that is who you
are that is who you are
[Music]
you are way maker Miracle Worker promise
Keeper in the darkness my God that is
who you
are you are way maker mirac worker
promise keeper light in the
darkness my God that is who you
are that is who you
[Music]
are let us then approach God's throne of
grace with
confidence so that we may receive Mercy
and find Grace to help us in our time of
need
[Music]
you unreel
me with a
Melody you surround me with the
song of
deliverance from my
enemies till all my my fears are
gone and I'm no longer a slave to
fear no I am a child of
God I'm no longer a
Sav
fear no I am a child
of
[Music]
God from my mother's
womb you have chosen
me love has called my
name God have been born
again into your
family your blood flows through my
vein and I'm no
longer a SL to
fear I am a child of
God I'm no longer a
to
fear no I am a child of God sing that
again I'm no
longer slain to
fear no I am a child of God oh I'm no
longer to fear
do I am a child of
[Music]
God
oh oh
oh
oh you sp
the were in perfect
you resued me so I could stand and
seeing I am a child of
God you split the SE so I could walk
right through it my fears are drown in
perfect
love you rescued me so I can stand and
sing I am a child of
[Music]
God I am a child of
[Applause]
God I am a child of God
[Music]
and I'm no
longer to
fear I am a child of
God I'm no
longer a slave to
fear I am a child
[Music]
God we are children of
God we are your
[Music]
children God thank you that your perfect
love drives out fear
that you saw us from the
beginning that you knit us together and
you see us
[Music]
today just as we are a whole person with
a past and a present and a
future and you say it is
good you are my child I have chosen you
I have loved you from the start
you say that you're not giving up on our
story you say that you will complete
your good
work that you do not abandon the work of
your
hand you are a good
God full of Mercy full of compassion
full of forgiveness and hope and tonight
God God would we rest in that kind of
love would we find it deep woven into
our fabric
God would we return to our first
love the one who has seen us and known
us from the
beginning and would we let that love
penetrate
all the pores of our
life would we let it seep into us and
change our story for the
better would we let it transform the way
that we relate to one another and our
world and our
Earth God would you keep loving
us would you keep leading us
[Music]
and would we keep following hard after
you thank you for who you
[Music]
are it's in Jesus name that we
pray
[Music]
amen would you guys just take a moment
to greet the people sitting near you and
then Brett will come and get us started
with our
message oh Grace and
peace welcome to the table uh my name is
Brett pronouns he him and uh it is a joy
it's a joy to be with you you all to
welcome you um into this space and as
always that includes those joining us
online y'all are not forgotten and uh
especially anyone here tonight who is
new uh new to the community thank you
for being with us I I really do um I
just I hope you find a god of compassion
a a Christ of love a community of
welcome here at the table so uh we are
in the midst this is week two in our
series titled holy shift a 21st century
faith and uh I like that series
title I sent it to the team early on
like hey I'm just you know I'm thinking
about this series and uh Jesse Watts was
like dude that's the best series title
you've ever come up
with I don't know maybe you overrated it
but we like you like the edginess we did
um so the the kind of hard of this
series you've been around the table for
a while you know um we do all sorts of
Series so for much of the Year we're
following the church calendar um and
then other times we'll do like a book of
the Bible um or a chapter or something
and kind of do that week by week but
other times we do just totally topical
and uh and so that's this series is a
very you know topical type thing and
it's it's kind of on purpose because
it's it's a chance to speak to something
you know things that feel timely and
relevant and so and to kind of apply the
gospel you know into that that context
so um where that's kind of the way this
series is going is it's we're just
taking a fairly critical look at culture
and the things like things we just take
for granted like in the same way fish
would take water for granted um you you
ask fish what's water you know you know
how do they like the water and they're
like What's water you know and it's kind
of similar this there's just things we
take in in the culture it's just part of
it you know it's you're too close to it
you can't see it so that's some of what
we're doing in this series is trying to
take a a fairly critical look at uh some
of those those things so with that in
mind the title of my message this week
is um holy shift
consumerism and so our scripture is Mark
chap 10: 17 through
22 it reads as Jesus started on his way
a man ran up to him and fell on his
knees before
him good teacher he asked what must I do
to in inherit eternal
life why do you call me good Jesus
answered no one is good except God alone
you know the Commandments you shall not
murder shall not commit adultery shall
not steal you shall not give false
testimony you shall not defraud you
shall not defraud on your father and
mother teacher he declared all these I
have kept since I was a boy Jesus looked
at him and loved him one thing you lack
he said go sell everything you have and
give to the poor and you will have TR
treasure in heaven then come follow
me at this the man's face fell he went
away sad because he had great
wealth so I did uh most of my Seminary
training in
Portland and from 2014 to 2018 most of
it that was online so the way it worked
was I would travel there for a week of
lectures every you know every semester
so including like summer winter so I was
lot lots of trips to Portland and that
was a season of my life where I um I'm
still kind of just by Nature pretty
Frugal but that was like a season where
I was like wanting to be very frugal so
I mean for example I wrote Spirit
Airlines uh oh yeah all in on the spirit
I was like can I have a drink of water
they're like yes that'll be $50 you know
I mean it's it's tough spirit's intense
you know
um but one because of this one of the
things I did was I stayed only in Airbnb
uh you know where and not like I rented
the pool house no no no no you know a
room in someone's house and so because
of this like I kind of got like a
snapshot of families in Portland it was
fascinating I I got a chance let's see
like some of the the first this is kind
of gender stereotypical but I stayed in
this um this single males home let's
just say you could tell it was a single
male like this the V the carpets had
never been vacuumed like ever I mean it
was just so it was so bad and I gave him
some feedback later like bro this is
this is bad you know um I stayed in a it
was a family of self-described atheists
that was and it was like very you know
they weren't subtle about it it was like
all the bumper stickers you know
anti-religious bumper stickers in the
cars uh their bookcases lined with the
toms of you know Richard Dawkins and
Christopher Hitchens you know and uh we
had like fascinating we had to we kind
of mostly I think tried to steer around
it you know kind of avoid the
uncomfortable G because I knew like I
was there for Seminary you know so it
was but we had you know a few few
moments um that were kind of kind of
weird but um then there was the time I
stayed in the backyard of some I stayed
in a yurt in someone's
backyard uh that was fun and cheap oh so
cheap um but my favorite place far was
uh Rosie and Pete's house they were this
kind of like upper middle class I guess
he'd worked like in the upper echelons
of Amazon on or something and then broke
away to do contract work so they're like
you know well off them and their two
kids living in this really nice house
but it I love staying there because it
was like it was fascinating so the first
time I I open the door I walk in and I
am just I'm just struck like you know
most Americans through the years we just
gather things you know just accumulate
things this house had like almost no
things it was great it was crazy I mean
that night I'm trying to like I need to
prep some dinner I like hey uh can you
point me in the direction of a cutting
knife and like oh sure yeah that door or
that drawer right there on the left I
open the drawer and it's just one sharp
cutting knife like that was it just
because that was it I I'm like hey do
you have a cutting board they're like oh
yeah right over there open the cupboard
just a cutting
board that was it this is how the whole
house was I go up to my room there's a
bed and a
lamp I open the closet folding table
folding chair I guess you want to sit
somewhere other than the bed you a chair
like it was just this is the whole house
like a wall would have one picture Max
two kind of Tastefully spread out they
they would I mean a table just one like
thing you so I of course you know I have
I'm just curious as a cat I'm like so uh
and I noticed your house doesn't doesn't
have many
things and uh I wasn't afraid of
offending because uh you know you could
tell it was on purpose and they get this
gigantic smile they wanted to be asked
you know huge smile and they say
yes we are
minimalists
and I was like yeah I picked up on that
you know and they went they they proceed
tell me some of the the story it all
happened like four or five years back
where they just realized they were like
any other American family and they just
gathered things things things things
they just stuff stuff stuff and they
they said uh I started to realize that
not only were these things not like they
weren't making us happy um they were
also kind of stressing us
out and so they just started like
getting rid of things and then they
implemented this rule like if something
new comes into the house something else
has to go and uh and they they were all
over it they they loved it they said uh
they said we just we want a life focused
on something other than
things Joshua Fields Milburn in his
Memoir everything that
remains said this understand every moth
is drawn to light even when that light
is a flame hot and burning
flickering the fire tantalizing the drab
creature with it its bluish white
illumination but when the moth flies too
close to the flame we all know what
happens it gets
burned incinerated by the very thing
that Drew it near for decades now I have
played the role of the moth lured by the
flame of consumerism pop cultures
beautiful configration a firestorm of
lust and greed and wanting a ha hunting
desire to consume that which cannot be
consumed to be fulfilled by that which
can never be
fulfilling do you
know that lust within yourself I don't
mean like sexual lust I mean that like
that desire that that kind of hunger for
like a new
thing a new thing
like and you just know don't you you
know like
this this is going to be it you know
like this is going to make me
happy and it
does for a little while right a minute
an hour a day I mean maybe for like a
major purchase a week maybe pushing a
month you know I don't know like the new
home is like pretty new you know but at
some point the new car smell it always
Fades doesn't
it there's a quote from laoo he said
there is no greater Calamity than not
knowing what is
enough there is no greater Calamity than
not knowing what is
enough or Proverbs
38-9 give me neither poverty nor
riches give me just
enough to satisfy my
needs perhaps the most unamerican
prayer in all of the Bible I mean can
you imagine like it is it's so uname I
mean again this is part of the culture
just who doesn't want more money you
know what I mean like yeah of course of
course just yes this is let's go all in
you know just that's the dream that's if
you're not going for that well what on
Earth are you going for you know just
it's just assumed I'm just it's an
insane prayer to us give me neither
poverty nor riches and there's a wisdom
there right it's not poverty can be its
own kind of
degrading grinding thing to be in lack
you know to be hungry
like but there's another problem you
know I want to read retell that story
from Mark 10 uh that we opened with and
uh again it's not going to be on the
screen because I'm taking a lot of
creative license with this this telling
what I'm really going to give you is an
it's an interpretation of that that
story and uh we'll see what kind of
resonates um here with you so there once
was a young
man his
sandals they were of the finest leather
his Robes of the softest most luxurious
material in fact he was so rich he
bathed every day a rarity in the first
century everyone in town knew him his
family was rich and upon recently
transitioning into adulthood he had
inherited a large sum of
money many thousands of acres of land he
was the Envy of every person who knew
him
in fact secretly they all wanted to be
him but little did they know that
something
noed within
him an ache and itch and no matter how
much money he threw at that gnawing no
matter how many homes he purchased or
parties he threw no matter how many
barrels of olive oil he sold or pats on
the back he received for his business
success it did not ease the
ache fact it made it worse it was like
poison ivy the more he
scratched the more it
burned did not make him happy did not
give him life to the full eternal life
ease peace
contentment so he decided to try
religion oh he threw himself into the
spiritual life he studied the scriptures
he said morning afternoon and evening
prayers he was in the temple for worship
every day he kept the Sabbath
scrupulously he even began keeping very
close track of his sins just kind of
monitoring making sure that they were
decreasing month by month by
month everything seemed on track
everyone around him was was of course
very
impressed they sh they said that he
should consider joining the
priesthood but it did not make him
happy did not give him life to the
full eternal life ease peace
and so in desperation he decided to
visit a local Saint and wonder work
after many days of searching he found
him and in
desperation he plunged himself in his
fancy robes into the dust bowing
low he said good teacher what shall I do
so that I may have eternal life life to
the full the saint looked at him with
compassion and said said have you kept
the Commandments do not lie and steal
and so on yes the young man said yes
I've done that for years now okay then
the Saints said there is only one thing
left to do and what is that the man
asked let
go said the
same let go of
what said the young man
everything you want me to let go of
everything the man asked yes
everything this is madness he said
why the saint responded because it is
precisely your clinging and attachment
that is making you
miserable in in order to enter the
kingdom you must become like a little
child
again
simple
open-handed
free this I cannot do said the
man I
know said
Jesus the way the uh official biblical
version of the story ends there in verse
22 says at this the man's face fell he
went away sad because he had great
wealth I think that's the key word there
he had he he possessed just simply that
he like he had it he had some things but
but specifically that he was attached to
it you see there were some uh female
followers of Christ disciples who we
know from book of and other places that
um they actually funded Jesus ministry
so they were quite wealthy and as far as
we know Jesus never asked them to give
everything up um I think even of like
the story of zakus you know the the man
who defrauded people whatever and and
there Jesus doesn't say okay well give
all that you have you know zakes is like
okay like no no he gave a lot but it
wasn't everything so so why did he ask
this man to do that I think that's the
question question that kind of that that
eats at me about this story why him I
think it was because he could see that
he was attached that the man didn't
realize that it was
precisely all of his
attachments that were making him anxious
and
miserable and so it is with us you see
the problem with
consumerism is not so much the things in
an themselves but our relationship to
them that that we of course we get
unhealthy
attached now what do I mean by attached
I'm thinking of the way that that we um
we tie sense of well-being to
things that's the
key right we we tie our sense of
well-being to things because I I think
most of us honestly if I ask you know
like are you attached to that I think
most even myself like
no no no it's people that matter isn't
it I mean we know this like it's people
that matter it's not about things oh
that's just things that that car that
you know I mean that's just things and
it's no B and but here's here's how you
know though that you're attached how do
you respond
emotionally when the thing goes
away breaks down stolen right the the
car gets
repoed the H like a wing of the house or
maybe the whole house burns to the
ground everyone's fine the whole family
gets out
safe and we're like oh my gosh my life
is
over what is that it's the very things
we would have said no no not me not tou
you know
but
suddenly it's kind of it reveals the
heart so what's the what's the shift
that's needed we need to shift from
consumerism to Inner
Freedom that is to say to
nonattachment by non-attachment I don't
mean becoming emotionally numb all right
it's not I don't mean that right
cold-hearted unloving towards others
that's not that I I mean rather a stance
which can continually lets go of
everything that would draw our hearts
away from love of God and love of
neighbor that's the trick anything that
would draw our hearts away from love of
God and love of neighbor and this is why
consumerism is such a profoundly
dangerous
flame a spiritually toxic thing again
not because things are bad things are
evil you know no it's not so much about
the things but it's the way we attach a
sense of our own well-being to those
things which means as good consumers we
kind of start out owning things but in
the end what happens they own
us so in closing I I want to kind of ask
how do we begin to kind of cultivate
this inner freedom I want to give you
three very like practical ways
um and these are things more to consider
you don't have to do all these but just
let this be kind of a jumping off point
for your mind and Imagination um number
one take some time to reflect on what
and how much you actually
need Ian it's a it's a stunning question
that we kind of never really face like
how much do I actually need back to the
aluku right how much is
enough H how many sharp knives do I
really need
it's I mean right it's and this keep
going with clothing with money with all
the things just how how much do we do we
actually need second take a month and
only buy a Necessities right things you
need and B if you're going to buy it buy
it
used this I guess doesn't apply to like
food or something but you know you know
you get it um third idea go through your
closet and donate to charity any article
of clothing you haven't worn in the last
12 months don't we always tell ourselves
like I'm going to wear it you know don't
you worry it's like been sitting in
there for seven years so of course 12
months you've been through all the
seasons so if you didn't wear it last
year it's probably not a
need as we do this may a holy shift
occur May Christ make us simple
openhearted generous and childlike again
unattached but more
emotionally and spiritually
engaged than ever
before in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy
Spirit
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
in the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine
we come as
consumers but in this moment not not
secular people buying things we come as
people taking in Christ hungry for
Christ and in a kind of strange Paradox
in a moment we take in Christ Christ
incorporates us Christ welcomes us
Christ consumes us so that's the the
kind of spirit in which I'd like you to
participate ipate in this tonight um the
way we're going to partake in communion
is we'll just go row by row here from
the front work our way back forming a
line right here um we practice what's
called an Open Table meaning if you're
here tonight and you'd like to
participate then you are free to do that
regardless of your exact you know
theology or denomination or whatever um
you are free to do that having said that
there's also no pressure um if you're in
a place where you're like don't want to
engage that that's okay too um you
should know the red is wine the white is
grape juice and then you can just
partake whenever and however you'd like
some people like to kneel up here some
take it immediately some like to return
to their their chairs but no one will
lead you through the exact moment of
partaking so this is the
table not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so
come you who have much faith and you who
have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you who have
tried to follow and you have
failed come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
for
you'd like to stand with us during this
last song you can or you can sit and
receive it but um in response to Brett's
message we just want to sing this um old
hymn take my life and let it be as a
time to truly offer ourselves and
practice that act of Letting Go that
Brett was talking about
[Music]
take my
life and let it
be
[Music]
consecrated Lord to
thee take my
moment and my
days let them flow oh in
ceaseless
praise let them flow in ceas let's
[Music]
pray let's sing together take my hands
and let them move take my hands and let
them
move at the
impul of thy
love take my feet and let them
be Swift and
[Music]
beautiful for
thee Swift and beaut
careful for
thee sing take my will take my
will and make it
thine it shall be no
longer
mine take my heart it is thy
know it shall be thy
Royal
Throne it shall be thy
[Music]
Throne take my
love take my love my Lord I
pour at thy feet in it
treasure
store take
myself and I will
be
ever
only all for
thee ever
only all for the
[Music]
one more time take my life take my life
and let it
be
consecrated Lord to
thee take my
moment and my days
let them flow in
SE
praise let them flow in
ceaseless
[Music]
praise thank you so much for joining us
this evening if you are new we would
love for you to fill out a card at the
table on your way out or just scan the
QR code on the screen to fill out an
online visitor
card that will allow us to follow up
with you and answer questions you may
have and say thank you for
visiting if you are in need of prayer a
hug or just general support come find me
after the service I would love to be
there for you however I
can generosity is a key aspect
of a life of adoration and worship to
give financially you can scan the QR
code or visit thetable tx.org
all
right let me send you into your week
with this blessing you can hold out your
hands in a posture to receive or just
open your hearts to these
words you are a child of God
you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with it's yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between know that you go with the go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you are and go filled
with God's holy spirit and a desire to
extend these same gifts to everyone you
come in contact with be blessed we'll
see you next
Sunday take my life and let it be